(Audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Hello!
- You guys,
hello!
- I'm such a big fan of yours.
- Thank you, thank you,
that song was gorgeous
- Oh, I didn't write it,
- by the way.
- but I loved singing it.
Yeah, it's such a pretty song, right?
- It is, it is.
- The whole album is good.
- Yeah, and Miley is just remarkable.
- Yeah, her voice too.
- Yeah.
- She's got that really
crazy cool vibrato.
- Yeah.
- Oh man.
- She actually guested
on "Two and a Half Men"
for a little while,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And she would just sit around
doing those little vocal trills.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Just, you know,
just off-hand.
- [Kelly] Just hangin' out.
- Just hangin' out, being,
doing these amazing things.
You're like, what?
- That was literally
like working with Ariana
on "The Voice".
We would just be backstage
and she's just constantly
like keeping her, like
even her really high,
like whistle tone,
- [Jon] Exactly.
- she's keeping 'em in check,
and I'm like, you're just
like sitting there like,
(Kelly emulates Ariana)
I was like, what in the world?
Like, yeah.
- It's like a superpower.
- People are crazy talented.
- Yeah, it is a superpower.
So, wait, so you grew up here?
- Yes.
- Now is this like,
like where I grew up, it
looks totally different.
Like it's, it used to
be like the countryside,
now it's like a metropolis,
comparatively speaking.
What is it like for
when you come back here?
- Well, New York is always New York.
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)
Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, but they,
but buildings just pop up
where you least expect them.
I mean, like, 'cause I grew
up here, you know, in the 70s.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Okay, so,
it's a little while ago
and it's so different
now.
- Yeah.
- Although, interestingly,
my wife says that I'm sexier
in New York.
- [Kelly] Okay, yeah.
Well, if you're dressing like this,
sir.
- It's obviously.
(audience applauds)
- Good to elevate your game.
- No, but I would.
- Hey, it turns out
I'm sexier in New York.
(audience applauds)
I was just making a joke,
'cause everyone's talking about,
I'm like, turns out I was a dog in LA.
Anyway, I was just kidding.
I'm totally kidding.
- Well, but the reason why, I realized,
is because I know where I'm going.
I know, because I grew
up here.
- [Kelly] Oh, your confidence.
- And, but like, apparently,
in every other city of the world,
I'm like, oh, where is the,
Google map said there was a thing here.
- Just so you know, that's me everywhere.
- Great.
- Even where I grew up.
- I'm the worst.
I can't find anything.